we've been talking about it what they
would have up their sleeve to keep
people from going to vote would there be
an event would there be something to
just not let this thing happen I think
that we are looking we're living at a
time where we're on borrowed time y um
we have had so many black swans happened
to us and this it is it amazes me
because when I was in 2006 I was saying
storm is coming this financial thing it
doesn't work and they were all like
where did you get your degree I'm like I
can see it because I haven't studied
what you stud you believe in the system
I can look at it and go these loans make
no sense okay and we were hit in 2008
and